it so I'm delighted to introduce our
plenary speaker for the day again he's a
research scientist at meta and India
will share really
um a really exciting overview of the
differential behind the scene and its
variance
thank you uh so I realized that like the
title is not fully grammatical because
uh everything that I'm going to talk
about is differential privacy I'm just
like going to take kind of
different uh views of different
different ways of formulation
differential values but let's think
about it as everything is one of the
differential private in this
okay so in the roadmap I'll start with
the Reconstruction tax and then
introduce the definition and then kind
of go to this like various ways of
defining differential privacy and my
prob my objective for the talk is to
connect is to First provide a historical
overview overview okay some history of
ideas how uh the lat from the attacks to
the oops
um
uh from the tax to to the uh defenses
and connect it with uh uh I'll like try
to make explicit connections with
inspiration Theory and whether you can
kind of start your kind of thought
engines kind of uh uh roaring and uh
kind of apply the tools or like think
about the tools that you have
uh and how the like bring to bear that
them to on
questions and privacy
okay so for um let's start with a very
stylish very simplistic model of
database access
we have a database that contains rows
name froze uh and a binary attribute
and obviously it's super simplistic but
uh it provides enough uh of the
substance and it's easy to see how these
ideas that kind of that work on this
data set databases uh they can extend to
more complex structures
and the uh to access the database you
name some of the rows that are
interested in the names are public
uh the attribute is hidden and uh you
learn the subset sum with the scalar
product between your vector and the uh
the vector of attributes
so uh obviously if uh kind of there's no
noise your ghetto get to ask and queries
to the database of course you can
reconstruct the entire database in
exactly and queries right
uh but what if uh the uh let's introduce
one character a curator of the database
is allowed to lie it's allowed to uh
um noise some uh uh like um kind of
instead of answering the queries
straight
uh you'll add some noise to the answers
and before you say aha like I like
that's like the center problem in
Collision Theory
um uh uh I'll allow the worst case uh
adversary
the adversary is going to be stifle it's
going to be cunning it's going to track
keep track of the query set it answer so
far and the noise is not necessarily a
sample from any particular distribution
um again it can be a result of a fairly
complex
uh not necessarily efficient process
and uh uh in in the first theorem that
uh the whose Prophet is like let me see
it like no I don't have it but it really
fits on one slide
uh if the mechanism has noise which is
always bounded by some upper bound to e
then there's exists an adversary that
not necessarily efficient that can
reconstruct the database to within four
times e positions
and that theorem like really like it's
an observation goes back to normal you
see him from 2003 from 20 years ago
and uh like the way of connecting this
to standard questions in um codeine
Theory it's like holistic coding except
that uh we're interested in any
candidates like anything that fits the
bill like not not not the entire list of
possibilities but like just one
uh so um okay so that's the statement of
that term
uh let me introduce another concept that
uh um and interestingly preceded yeah go
ahead how many queries are allowed in
that one there was no mention of queries
foreign
X is not efficient
um uh and this line of extraction
tactics precedes differential privacy
partially because there was no consensus
definition of what private or what
privacy is
and what they said let's define what you
don't know and like this is what they
say in the paper we don't know what
privacy is
but uh we'll know what privacy isn't
so they say that uh a mechanism is
blatantly non-private
obviously
just in your face on private if an
addresser can reconstruct the database
that agrees with the wrong truth
on all but a negligible fraction of of
of Interest
right in that those cases we say well
obviously this is not privacy
and the demonstrate that this is uh look
that's the that's the the meat of the
paper of celebrate paper that kind of
sufferedness with the number of words
uh including the Google price
um uh it uh uh
um if the um
uh noise is a uh negligible fraction of
square to pen
with a linear number of queries uh we
can uh efficiently reconstruct almost
entire database
and inefficiently
uh uh but still like blatantly uh we can
violate privacy if the adversary is
bounded on uh uh this much smaller than
Square defend noise on a fraction of
queries that is a bit more than like
one half plus Epsilon uh fraction of the
of the answers and can lie arbitrarily
on other queries and of course we don't
know which are which right
um and by arbitrarily I mean like not
only the noise can be unbounded that's
going to be easier okay we'll just throw
out what we'll ignore those queries
right but the noise can be adversarial
and can be kind of made us to confuse
like made us specifically designed
computers
and in Fallout book
um there is uh like uh conceptually a
simpler like using some query analysis
uh that's a kind of improvement on on
this on this book where the number of
queries is strictly linear
uh in a very interesting book um and I
didn't mention the technical tools and
uh uh generation and uh within this
Fallout book The apply uh LP decoding uh
there's an efficient uh algorithm that
uh
um kind of abstracts us this result
um where the noise can be uh is bounded
on 77 percent
uh uh okay it's functions okay so it's
an efficient algorithm and the adversary
can
um uh lie arbitrarily on
23 of the price and 23 it's it's a hard
constant
it's a threshold for this particular
algorithm and for all LP based decoding
algorithms
um but uh there is definitely some gap
between uh this result and this results
so here uh the um uh the algorithm is uh
the Reconstruction algorithm is
non-efficient here it is we don't really
know what happens in between
I wouldn't call it a central problem in
this line of work but kind of it's
something that you can consider
um okay so
um uh all these results the led us to
um kind of the observation that can be
formulated as a fundamental law of
information recovery that states Loosely
that overly accurate answers
to too many questions will destroy
privacy in a spectacular matter
and uh to First approximation the
content of this talk and of this entire
line of work on on differential privacy
is providing uh mathematically rigorous
principled way of capturing this
intuition
or what it means to be overly accurate
and how many questions is too many
okay so enter differential privacy and
I'll skip kind of other attacks that
kind of sort of like help us to narrow
down all this definition
you'll see that picture or very similar
uh pictures multiple times throughout
this day because there is going to be
multiple talks in different her privacy
every single one of them will have a
version of this picture
so prepare to kind of
it's just the the first of May
uh so uh in our setup database we call
it database as dng Prime if they differ
in one person's data
and uh the analyst interacts with the
database via its curator
the curator whose job is to protect
privacy of the database
and the Analyst at the end of the day it
interacts like ask queries that it's the
analysis either interested in or are
specifically designed to build privacy
of a single individual
at the end of the day the analyst
scratches attack and and wants to decide
whether it interacted with the G or D
Prime
whether he lives in the like red like
red pill or the blue pill right and uh
importantly the analyst knows the entire
database
except for this one bit so he knows D he
knows D Prime he knows the difference
between them what he doesn't know is
Rich of the rules
uh reaches the real database behind the
curator
and um
like
how would greater kind of protect like
accomplish its task
the um uh the definition again
loosely
uh it will uh guarantee that the
mechanisms the Creator's output on D is
going to be nearly the same as on the
prime
if this is the case then the uh the
analyst doesn't stand a chance right can
tell the difference
okay so um how do we capture that
intuition how do we say well two
distributions are close to one another
and this is where kind of uh I didn't
mention that my background as a computer
scientist as a cryptographer and uh for
me kind of the first like the first
reflexive reaction would be statistical
distance
again modern cryptography is based on
the notion of statistical distance
nothing else like literally like you can
like the entire textbooks okay so
statistical distance plus computational
kind of arguments
um uh
um so this is like what cryptographers
know and love and this is like they
don't really know the world outside it
and uh okay so let's plug in like use
statistical distance
okay so
um uh and then like if you try to think
about it well kind of any two databases
of size n are at most and distance apart
like you can throw out all elements of
one database
add all elements or like replace like
replace every single element of the
database
and like you and steps you can work from
any database to another to any other
database
and uh so consider like this sequence of
steps
then uh if we have a mechanism that uh
produces
uh different answers on uh uh uh like
work like so if you have a mechanism
then of course by triangle inequality uh
it's um statistical distance between
these two extreme points is going to be
the sum of the statistical bounded by
the sum of the statistical statistical
distances on the intermediate steps
which is of course uh bounded by the N
times the max distance
and if you want
our mechanism to be to be telling us
something useful about databases that
are extreme points so the Spectrum one
is like all zeros database another all
one database or like one is database uh
of like I don't know like uh and another
database of gorillas right like it's
um if you want to see some difference
between them then it bounce From Below
the maximal distance that is allowed
between two sub two databases two
neighboring databases
so if we hope to use statistical
distance then
it necessarily needs to be bounded by
one over n from below
and what's wrong with that well one
overall statistical distances allows
publishing single
arbitrary record from the database right
which doesn't vote well for a privacy
definition right I give you a
differential privacy and by the way I
can publish any records in the database
right like it sounds wrong
secondly and now like we are talking
about like intuitions uh but kind of
that's valid like that's important
uh an additive one percent chance and
probability of an unlikely event is not
the same as a one percent chance
probability of a likely event
if I tell you that like with one percent
uh probability
I am I look for matter but as known as
like like uh uh AKA Facebook
um and uh if uh I'm able to guess that
kind of to Target an ads to you with a
somewhat better probability it's not
exactly the same that your probability
of being hit by a bus goes additively by
one percent right like we are talking
about like uh two events with very
different utilities right like in one
event of being targeted net has like a
high kind of background probability and
you don't mind it at all and the
privilege of being hit by a bus today is
like tiny and you'd rather stay like to
do for that event to stay to the for
that probability to stay tiny
and that was the intuition that led to
the proposal of epson differential
privacy
where we bound uh the difference between
distributions by a multiplicative amount
and because we are talking about
multiplicative multiplicative amounts
it's convenient to put it in the
exponent hence the definition of
different comprising
and I can make
differential like privacy definitions
all day long
uh but ultimately it comes down to the
guarantees what I uh in what ways I can
explain the definition to a person who
cares
right and the definition the
interpretation that I like the most is
what I would refer to as bad outcomes
interpretation
so there are
some I'm trying to convince you to
contribute your data to my uh to my
database to answer my survey like to do
something like kind of to click on allow
to track again being like a met employee
and there are certain outcomes
uh that you don't like to see being hit
by a bus having your medical insurance
denied
uh or being stopped at the border like
like some like unfortunate events that
can it'll be follow you
and uh the guarantee that I give you is
not that those bad events won't happen
you can still get hit by a bus I cannot
help that what I can help is that the
probability of that event won't increase
multiplicatively by modern e to that
right
and then you can kind of make your
Calculus and decide to contribute my
your data to my database
so yeah that's the mathematical
expression of this statement
okay so uh that's gonna be a good start
but then like let's run around and see
whether like it's a definition that
people may appreciate my life but
whether like the second question is
whether uh this definition is easy to
work with
and it turns out that it's just
wonderful it checks out this very
important points
number one it's robust to auxiliary data
and this is where the definition that as
formulated uh it's really super
pessimistic I give to the adversary D
and D Prime right and for machine
learning people for statisticians it's
craziness like it's why would we want to
protect uh we'll care about privacy of
all elements in the database and we give
for free to the adversary the entire
database except for this one bit not the
role the bit whether the throw is
present tracks
why is this uh uh uh kind of a good
property of a definition because it runs
like if you if our definition is very
very strong it has this remarkably
strong quality
that no matter what adversary knows
about the world
the definition won't collapse
the definition the differential will
retain its capability
uh and um uh and this is uh really the
reason why differential privacy is so
much uh uh kind of
more powerful better lack of a better
world than many Alternatives like Canada
and like Canon 80 and its variants
because
uh it collapses
uh in the presence of some naturally
occurring
um auxiliary data for example if two two
hospitals the uh share overlapping
populations can both apply candidates
here and then they release their data uh
in um kind of without coordination then
uh uh the uh privacy guarantees of
either Hospital can just totally be
violated
so a second property is post processing
is a mechanism is differentially private
whatever we do with the armpit of the
mechanism is definitely private and
again mathematically it's a terrible
statement but uh conceptually it's super
super useful
once you're French for private always
differentiate private from the
perspective of Building Systems this is
the property that you want to have like
you draw the line like you kind of
Define your private interface you don't
care what happens after after that and
again wearing my cryptographer's hat
that's kind of a super nice property to
have
it's composable
and uh uh this is where kind of with
some benefit of hindsight why I put
absence in the exponent because it has
this super nice property that I have two
mechanisms applied to the same or
overlapping data sets doesn't matter
um the if I output uh if I share outputs
of both mechanisms then the resulting
mechanism will have uh the its
parameters will nicely add up
and finally uh a uh if my assumptions
about uh the like in records of the
database are slightly off for example
families the officer social economic
characteristics uh demographic Etc then
um the financial privacy won't collapse
if rows are correlated uh it will become
weaker but kind of it will still retain
some of its protection
yes
um it takes uh with two iron proof right
uh I'm not sure I can kind of just
really sketch it but like uh
the robust like the auxiliary
information like sort of auxiliary
information won't help the adversary and
then there's everything
uh but honestly kind of it
requires a little bit of just staring at
the definition
okay uh so those are super nice
properties but how we like do the
mechanisms that Implement differential
privacy exist
and again it turns out that a very
simple really kind of the first
mechanism that can that comes to mind
will check out the box like we'll meet
the definition of differential privacy
and this is where kind of when we add
LaPlace noise to the output
for a more complex data sets of course
your machines can be much more
sophisticated for this very simplistic
access
LaPlace mechanism will suffice
and uh how to see that it meets the
definition definition of differential
privacy well kind of uh if the data the
adversary knows the entire database
except for one row uh it knows the sum
over all uh rows except for one right so
the only uncertainty that adversary has
is like whether the value of the sum is
like 100 or 100 100 plus one
and the LaPlace noise will hide that
information like uh the the adversary
only gets to see one sample from that
distribution
and uh the um
posterior probabilities are going to be
exactly within equilateral
so uh I hope that convince you that
differential privacy provides a very
satisfying answer
to uh to this kind of digital outcome
that uh it gives us an ability to track
um kind of
scroll back so that's a simple
mathematical property but it gives rise
to a very uh nature look very uh useful
concept which is a privacy budget
because uh no uh we can add and divide
our privacy loss uh in arbitrary
quantities and those quantities will
kind of nicely
uh compose like it will nicely add up
together right so it's an interesting
kind of very
um kind of really serendipitous
mapping of the mathematical concept to
uh kind of our intuitive understanding
of what privacy is which is like the
non-renewable resource that can be
consumed in small chunks
okay so uh it was like uh
generated a lot of excitement in the Cs
Community than in the statistic among
statisticians in among uh people who
work with Nathan but then uh fairly
quickly we ran into problems into
troubles with differential patches
one is that it's somewhat too rigid no
event no matter how small can be ignored
so a tiny little imperfection in kind of
the distributions on GG Prime will give
you game away right like it can be can
be the Smoking Gun that like just
exposes like breaks through your
Enterprise
uh and uh in kind of related like and I
will see you I'll show you on the next
slide that uh it doesn't kind of
it it composes in a very brutal way like
if you take an um an absolutely private
mechanism and iterated end times
kind of pure privacy budget goes out
goes up clean early
and why is this kind of
something wrong with that so imagine you
have
um a kind of biascoin 55 55 Tails 20.5
percent had you flip it once and your uh
posterior on uh
or the Privacy loss of Bitcoin will
decrease by uh 0.2 right a little bit
like your confidence that you deal with
the biascoin versus a Fair coin will uh
increase by the small amount
but imagine that we flip this coin a
hundred times and every single one of
these times it landed tails
right that happens with the negligible
small probability
with literally point
0.55 to 100 like almost like never ever
happens
but the privilege is that uh if this
coins were biased and then landed uh
fails it's even less
and it's less by this like giant amount
right
so we have this like tiny uh uh chance
of this adverse event happening
but it can completely kind of it sort of
controls uh the guarantee of of
differential privacy that sucks
and uh it led to the emergence of the
definition of absolute Delta
differential privacy where we add like
this little slack of Delta that can be
intuitively interpreted as
but we have pure Japan
almost always accepted privilege to
Delta I'm simplifying a little bit like
it's not like the definition is what it
is but like the kind of the cement like
the kind of intuitive interpret
interpretation interpretation is that
Delta kind of we can hide Adverse Events
in this uh uh Delta probability
and uh again it kind of uh fortunately
uh it satisfies all those same
properties that I listed before except
that uh like now we have the parameters
and it's composable in this manner right
nice and good
yeah
but okay so
uh uh
Delta becomes this nuclear option with
purple the Delta we can publish the
entire database right uh or with
probability one we can publish a Delta
fraction
of inside database
and again for a privacy diffusion kind
of sucks so it leads to this
recommendation that Delta B much less
than 1 over n and ideally kind of
like some like at least a polynomial
fraction or supplemental fraction of the
of n
okay and where we use Epsilon Delta
and two common use cases for Epsilon
definition is the gaussian noise and the
best computation terms and I'll walk you
through these examples
okay so for the girlfriend noise
um it's the alternative LaPlace
mechanism so instead of adding LaPlace
noise we'll be adding gaussian why do we
want to do that
like it's a
the option definition a gaussian
distribution everyone loves it like
statisticians know what to do with it
it's strictly symmetrical close under
addition uh it behaves like noise if I
tell a statistician that's like that's
that's the database and by the way I'll
be eating LaPlace noise to to Aquarius
they'll say huh like I need to go back
and like we will confirms to kind of
like accommodate my accommodated my
statistical analysis if I say and by the
way I add gaussian noise we'll say sure
yeah of course like that's like what
I've been working with all my life right
so gaussian noise is something that is
like naturally integrates into
existing statistical procedures
uh and it's going to be slightly
constricted but unfortunately this is
where it kind of uh it like it cannot
satisfy the definition of pure
absolutely differential privacy and this
is where we use absolute doubles
depression privacy with taxes like it's
fails
where consideration between red and blue
curves goes up we say well kind of it
will go up but it happens with the
diminishing the small probability
and for Epsilon Delta uh uh like for uh
uh a Delta no matter how arbitrary small
uh there is going to be some absence
okay so second I uh uh mentioned that uh
N4 compositional pure differential
privacy satisfies
what just like accumulus linearly
um for there is a class of theorems
called Advanced composition composition
theorems uh and uh Peter kind of knows
everything about that uh about those
competition theorems uh in some defined
form one of them can be a formulate this
Folds
if you start with an absolute
differential part of mechanism
pure Japan privacy we iterate they say
let's say making it doesn't matter like
just like again I'm giving a simplified
version of this of this composition
theorem uh we iterate the same mechanism
or a simple mechanisms that all satisfy
absolutely absolutely
and uh uh for any Delta that you can
think about
um the composition will satisfy
square root n times something like a
problem that depends on dog
so the Privacy budget will grow in
proportion to the square root of the
number of iterations
and like kind of if you go to this like
kind of coin example you see where it's
coming from right
uh sometimes like in except for this
pathological cases sometimes like the
coin in the lens has sometimes tails and
when the land heads will confuse the
atmosphere when they hand land Tails
still help them right like that's kind
of the uh the intuition
uh and indeed it can be made uh rigorous
and here I sketched uh the uh the proof
of that statement of the theorem uh I'm
not going to walk through that except by
saying well if you define the private
suppose variable and we trace the
evolution of this privacy Source
variable and uh
uh really kind of what what kind of what
helps us is that as a Muslim policy
again I'll
not expecting you to understand the like
to kind of Grog that theorem right away
but just wanted to put on the slide
because I'll come back
but
there are like some problems with the
Epsilon Delta differential types
so I mentioned that Delta has this
nuclear option usually has this
catastrophic failure mode
but gusher mechanism doesn't have that
note for any Delta there's some Epsilon
that got from Magnum statistics it never
ever exposes the database in its full
Glory right
second I said well kind of we want to
use uh Epsilon Delta when we compose
magnesiums right
but uh and like we can write down this
theorem that's going to be nice and nice
in there
but when we try to iterate it when we
try to compose Epsilon Delta mechanisms
then doing that in optimal matter manner
is sharp which is like very very hard
and uh when uh we have like for any
adult we have some Epsilon then consider
just no terms at all like no one
attempted to to write it down completely
like like that's so we introduced
Epsilon Delta for to capture Advanced
computation theorems but it doesn't
compose with itself in the nice in a
nice manner
and finally that's a technical but like
again still annoying property that I
have these two use cases government
investment composition theorems but if I
try to compose
uh like kind of taking action mechanism
capture its properties as a personal
Delta applied Advanced composition
composition theorems then I kind of
there's a gap compared to when I apply
like analyzing mathematical properties
of multi-dimensional gaussian mechanism
which is kind of travel to do the
commitment analytically
okay so after a while it felt like we
are like trying to fit like this uh
Square packs and round holes right like
or something that didn't quite fit
and um it led us on the path of like
think about better notion supposes
and uh uh so absolutely differential
privacy is uh kind of that property
and then uh uh kind of uh
we uh
stumble upon like that's like there is
no better way of of of of of kind of
capturing that like we literally kind of
just came across uh the notion of rainy
Divergence and foreign
kind of uh someone tells us that uh well
kind of we have this differential
privacy notion
uh and there's running that versions at
Infinity that coincides exactly with DP
Epsilon DP then the most initial
question what about like
final folders like what about like if
they're not going for intimacy right
and uh enter Randy differential price
so the uh
definition of privacy is not if you're
not familiar with that I hope most of
you do uh
uh it's the like office moment of the uh
uh
I would say privacy lost variable like
the ratio between these two
distributions
log scaled right
and
um uh at order one and it's defined uh
like as stated is defined for uh client
orders which is not one uh at one it's
scale Divergence and uh it defined by
continuity uh and some same for Infinity
and the definition of running different
surprise just writes itself right we
have the Divergence and this is what
kind of what we end up with like like
that's like a very
natural kind of uh thought
and uh at Infinity as I said Randy
Divergence coin size with pure
differential privacy that's good
for find orders it implies it's a
strengthening of Epsilon Delta
differential position so for find others
Alpha Epsilon RDP it implies Epsilon
Delta differential privacy for all Delta
uh and Epson just like let's copy it
here and we have some additive term from
Delta and and the water
okay again as I said like we can make
privacy definitions all day long but
like they are only as good as people
will uh kind of feel that uh they get
something something out of them right
they're only as good as the guarantees
they give to the final final consumer
so going back to the beta interpretation
so for Epsilon differential privacy your
the probability of a bet event goes up
by introduction
multiplicatively for Epsilon Delta
differential privacy it goes up by its
Epsilon plus this annoying Delta term
and for our Alpha absolute differential
privacy RDP
we get like something very close to
Epsilon differential privacy except that
this probability
will get raised to this to this funky
power
that depends on the order when Alpha is
infinity that just drops out
if Alpha is one we go don't get anything
useful it's called Divergence
um if Alpha is finite we get some
increase in probability
but importantly there is no nuclear
option
if the base probability was Zero
it will stay zero right
and
look we can relax it a little bit if the
the probability of a bad outcome was
Tiny it will stay tiny it may increase
multiplicatively by a significant amount
if it was 10 to the minus 6 and Alpha is
2 then
we'll take the square root of it out of
it look it becomes the probability of a
bad event was 10 to minus six it became
10 to the minus 3 which is maybe
annoying that's why I kind of we like
Alphas to be high
5 10 right but like if Alpha is 10 then
10 to minus 6 to the power of uh nine
tens well kind of people live with it
right
uh yes
I think you can oh
yeah so uh uh
um and and again that's like uh when I
saw that that uh the this composition
properties here
uh kind of I thought like I saw kind of
the acquirising Alexandria sinking right
uh because like that just Can Happen by
coincidence right like that's exactly
what we want from a private definition
that it composes well
and if you go back to the less
competition composition term the proof
that I put up like as I mentioned the uh
like we Define the Privacy loss variable
and really
um kind of the what mathematically is
going on is that they're trying to
capture capture the large deviation of
the Privacy lost variable over like
multiple iterations
and this is what Azuma Stone quality
gives us and if you look at the azuma's
inequality uh that uh it switches to the
uh expansion moments it applies
marketing quality
and this information
the switch into the moments of the
um of the Privacy Law function is
exactly what's captured by radio
Divergence so we are not losing any
information when we
uh shift from uh differential privacy
terraneous diversion so that's exactly
what the profit investment Advanced
computation theorem means
uh so um we preserve all the goodness of
advanced composition while also having
kind of this super nice composition
property
so now like we can have like a little
bit of fun with uh drawing this like
what I refer to as rainy budget curves
for any Alpha and remember let's see uh
this uh uh uh or any Divergence is
monotonin uh for any Alpha we can have
some yeah
you can Define it it just it doesn't
give at least I don't know how to
translate it into using types here in
kicks right so it's not kind of
symmetrically uh interesting uh
definition but mathematically it's all
different
okay so for all final orders we can talk
about a budget at that order
uh and we have to to make two mechanisms
uh uh that are applied independently
then uh their application will just kind
of build the sum of their budget drops
for all Alpha there are budgets will
will add up
and uh yeah so for LaPlace mechanism we
can draw kind of this line for the
gaussian mechanism it's lying is
straight
so it captures the fact that and then
like uh if we start adding straight
lines then of course the result is going
to be straight right like so uh in some
way if uh the canonical mechanism for
Pure differential privacy was LaPlace
the canonical mechanism for brand new
differential privacy is gaussian because
it routines it's like it's super well
composable
uh and uh it suggests uh kind of as a
way of like practically tracking keeping
track of privacy but just you just like
decide in advance on some number of
folders and keep track of privacy budget
and those at those orders
and just like it will end up
uh and uh kind of uh importantly like
not satisfyingly uh I would say that uh
like uh so even though like I insist
that like uh uh the way uh that writing
a differential property was defined uh
in uh in a paper from 2016 is kind of
morally correct it's really bubbled up
as a kind of a multiple Works in Iraq at
the same time we all Converge on the
same mathematically mathematical
substance looking at the higher orders
of the
um of the Privacy loss variable and
again it suggests that this definition
is not something that was invented it
really was out there like for us to kind
of Discover it
just like platonic concept of uh of math
yeah I guess maybe another way of saying
it is
function of the Privacy loss rather
variables
it's really Unleashed uh kind of uh a uh
a lot of work on alternative privacy
comments again the con the goal here is
not to uh is to answer our original
question how many questions how kind of
uh provide the kind of the converse to
the statement that answers to too many
questions with uh too much accuracy will
lead to privacy about right we want to
say
we want to have a way of capturing what
is too many and what is to uh uh uh too
accurate
and uh
collectively it's referred to like this
by the book is referred to private
accountants and uh the better satisfied
uh composability uh properties and uh
semantic uh interpretations like do you
have to proceed to something meaningful
but uh uh the work on based on radio
diversions it kind of is good for proven
theorems if you're like doing
practical analysis then you can afford
to step away from look nice theorems and
use numerical algorithms and this is a
lot of this work to do
uh yep and uh finally yeah so uh this is
like really like uh so I hope that at
the end of my talk and if I sort of give
you some ideal how we stop answering we
kind of capture intuition behind this uh
uh this uh law of information recovery
and uh here I just want to uh kind of
uh
acknowledge uh the um kind of the magic
of this place uh of Berkeley so uh the
uh local for any work introduced very
Divergence it appeared in the uh in the
proceedings of the broadcast Symposium
on statistics and probability from 1961
and I looked up the table of content of
that Symposium and it's really who is
who of uh statistics and information
Theory uh it's Belmond Blackwell those
are names that I recognize uh probably
you'll have your own tortellinos dancing
um uh so um on the next page we have
cross call we have uh crawl renier this
is like the the book that uh introduced
the French
diversions
uh 2K and like one name that stands out
is jacobit yeah
he is father of Paul Wolfe it's the uh
the neocon the architect of the rock war
um uh yeah
but uh uh and here I kind of just want
to say that uh
we are really blessed of having
opportunity to to sample here at the
Simon's Institute uh that kind of uh
growing up like in Liberia like where
I'm growing academically up in the
barrier that institution did exist I
feel you should feel fortunate that you
have no percentage to come here
um uh and hopefully you can have 60
years from now or 70 years like 60 years
from now people will refer to kind of
the program of this Symposium and he
could recognizes her names uh uh there
are like our names there okay so the
concluded on a technical note uh so
running a differential privacy it's a
general generalization of relaxation of
pure General privacy and hoping it fixes
some of the kind of origin scene of
absolute Delta different her privacy and
that is very very powerful but also kind
of has since its flaws and uh uh
definitely it's not the end like it's at
the beginning that I encourage you all
all of you to think about it in the
principle way using your best uh uh your
best tools that you have in your
disposal
thank you
well thank you for the wonderful talk so
questions
so I guess for one case of related
facial privacy you can recover Epsilon
DT right and so you wanna if you wanna
optimize mechanisms for Epsilon DP you
can optimize for that particular output
you think it's too strict to optimize
for the whole curve of alpha d uh Alpha
uh
it's definitely an interesting problem
and even more interesting uh no I won't
say more but like
we can't answer even a basic question of
what uh how on budget curves are
admissible what are by looking for
physical
right and uh kind of for radio
Divergence it's a well-known question of
what kind of uh uh would first uh can be
can result from uh what the different uh
values of alpha our twist is that are
guaranteed this to save it
and that control that uh uh rules out
some of the curves that uh are possible
without the guarantee right so that's
kind of an interesting uh
uh constraint that we have uh that I
don't think it's been addressed but uh
so we don't already know what curves are
visible and definitely we don't know how
to optimize if you did make curve how to
find the mechanism that is going to
match your step
a related question so
we talked about going from
Alpha Ready DP to Epsilon Delta and in
fact it involves an optimization of
reality but intuitively could you
not what's happening from the alpha to
the Delta so it Delta we understand
right it's this
well loss of privacy in some sense
or what what's happening with the alpha
honestly uh okay so I'll be looking at
uh already differential privacy for a
long time for for a while
and yeah for me that's a good way to
satisfying your energy so
and again like people get confused with
this year Alpha and somehow like uh
ultimately
in my professional life
everything I do ultimately I translate
to action on that right because for like
it looks well like when you they see
Delta small like 10 to minus nine kind
of the can get Can it can ignore that
right
um with uh Alpha you
you cannot okay it's you'll apply
everywhere so
um
um yeah I'm optimize like whether
absolute Delta is like historical
mistake or it's actually what people
want
um
I guess related to Larita's question I
think maybe what she was after is
there's a very nice operational
interpretation for Epsilon Delta you can
view it as a binary hypothesis test and
we know how to reason and talk about
that test we now connected to membership
inference attack so on and so forth for
Alpha Epsilon many DP could we do
something similar sure you can
I mean it's it's not very obvious how
the outfit is not actually
it is but yeah go ahead all right
um so maybe this is obvious I'm not sure
but is it is there a good way to to get
the Alpha Epsilon um RDP with like when
we have categorical data like we can't
just add gaussian noise to indicator
so there's you have different privacy
for all the mechanisms that you know in
Paris about including critical data that
will become the keyword with the
experience uh but uh yeah I just didn't
want to kind of directly hopefully
sometimes in the afternoon Bill I don't
know
Divergence and I've seen it as how much
you're penalizing how much you care
about pales
I just wanna that seems reasonable
explain them
Square means they just adapted but she
just
figures
about the model
so uh
uh so the other story is definitely
allowed to be adapted
in fact remember where
whether it actually is uh I don't think
uh I don't think another case with the
tradition
uh but it's known kind of would mind if
that person would adaptive or this
attacks to be organized that's very
successful
people know that can happen if let's say
you have a service 99 otherwise
but inefficient is allowed again uh it's
been a while since kind of I
um updated like kind of checked the
ground foot on the slide but I believe
this question is still outstanding what
we do know is that for helping with LG
equality fails below
and about that section we don't know
what happens even inefficient so
inefficiency in efficiency we know that
uh what information terrific we
reconstruct uh data the data
when leverage
with probability anywhere more than half
can buy half because the
network certain halfway to database is
combined all zeros are well or works and
you can have like an answer queries with
probability one car for me
the reason to accommodations
three more questions
so if you showed aside uh showing that
you know if you want to compose you know
a bunch of Epsilon Delta mechanisms that
it's like P sharp completely very hard
problem and you showed like this
composition theorem for rainy
divergences Epsilon one plus Epsilon two
does that like is that optimal
composition
yes
okay so let's take the speaker again